[Music]
thank you how come you don't like the
old town alleyway look at all these
people
so you're saying Taiwanese people don't
like it as much as a tourists and
foreigners it's definitely more of a
tourist spot but it's so cool there's so
much food it is cool it's just
we are here for a very specific reason
this is our next stop we are going to
the lighting a lantern thing apparently
you write your wishes on this Lantern
and when you write your wishes on in the
fly straight up there's a high
propensity that the reason will come
through now when Muriel did this before
she met me she wished that her prince
charming would come to her and so her
wish came true
so why yours today you have to think
you'll enter as it goes up in the sky
[Music]
fried rice inside yay well that's plus
guard oh hello
the salty the fried rice is perfectly
seasoned you have the charred roll mark
almost a little bit spicy this is
definitely a must try it was so good
swap oh look oh I see
we're all family about it awesome so
when we were in when we had Joe fun I
wanted to try this really bad but Becky
suggested that I try this over here
instead it's a wild boar sausage and
they grill it over an open fire and they
slice in the added garlic in between it
and we don't meet garlic and Fuji is one
of my favorite things on earth and I'm
gonna enjoy this
good and once again is that Taiwanese
flavor of sweet and savory there's
always like a hint of sweetness and
everything that they do and it's even
with this up to some this boar sausage
that's useful
[Music]
you know which one you're gonna let
beginner right yeah no I don't yeah I
just gotta let my mind go the first
thing I think of would I'd be like all
right David's first lantern I've had my
baby fat for 28 years
tall superficial lose my baby I guess
that's not super official well I like it
becomes spider-woman
yeah this is something that I recently
wanted to do I want to retire before I'm
at the age of 35 and one of the bigger
reasons why I want to do that is because
I think watching my parents for like
literally from Monday through Sunday for
a majority of their life and for them
their purpose in life was to make sure
that me and my brother had food in our
stomach they you know building the
church and you know kind of making sure
that we had everything that we wanted
and needed and because of their dreams
it kind of allowed me to live my life
the way I wanted to so for me I don't
want my wife could be just built around
my career I know a lot of people out
there feel like you have to work for the
rest of your life and do what you love
which is perfectly fine and I completely
agree with that
but I don't want to work and have that
be the only reason why I wake up in the
morning so I want to retire before the
I'm 35 because there's a lot of things
in life I want to create before I pass
away so
this is one of my big big dreams want to
win the lotto so can you explain the
deep in behind that leaf
I mean it's not like
I'm gonna ask for something about money
just win a lottery happiness for me is
spending it with the people that you
really really care about and that's
always going to be the person that
you're going to be married to eventually
or the person that you're married with
your family and if you continue to grow
in developing relationships for the day
that you die there's not going to be a
single day that you live that's not
going to be fulfilled because it's
always about the people that are around
you and I know that a lot of times I
think we focus on the wrong people and
when you spend your time your focus on
people that aren't important to you that
bring you down that aren't supportive of
what you want to do this is what you
should always bring back to your love
your family so Muriel I'd heard that
little side comment she goes all your
girlfriend that could be anybody in the
future so I do an arrow on my thing for
her name said that I heard somebody say
that life is short now know when you
know you don't know the end of the
chapters when that's going to happen so
might as well spend your quality time
precious time with the ones you love you
know great food great memories go to a
different country with them oh joy you
know swing the time with the room nice
you ready to fly this thing I'm ready to
fly to state what oh yeah another thing
that you notice about maybe I should put
another ways can my girlfriend get a new
pair of ears she could not listen to
anything
I'm like oh I know please yes I'm ready
to play are you hungry
why the Pope
Oh
[Music]
so we just got done flying the lanterns
into the sky after we wrote all of our
wishes for whatever category was it was
health wellness happiness and money and
stuff like that you know to be honest
with you when I was younger I never
thought that I would even travel this
much probably wasn't a part of something
that I really wanted to do it wasn't
something that I thought was within my
means and not on top of that I didn't
have any interest in it because I didn't
have any thoughts of like expanding what
I knew outside of Sacramento and because
of that I was a very close-minded person
this experience was super awesome did
you enjoy it
doing it with me
[Music]
if you look right in front of me we have
a friggin amazing waterfall I don't even
know that this was one of the
attractions that we would have come to
this area but when Becky was talking
about the waterfall that we were going
to go to I didn't think it was going to
be this amazing in this big so currently
when you walk up to this thing water is
going to be spraying everywhere it's
going to get all in your face there's a
whole bunch of tourists are kind of
pushing their way through but this is a
waterfall in so fun sea thing so fun and
a shirt fund and it's going to be a
pretty amazing sight for everybody to
see it's massive I kind of wish I could
jump in into the water see what happens
but I'm almost 100% sure I'm gonna die
I never see such huge waterfall like
this before it's amazing
so refreshing wouldn't be one like take
a pictures like beautiful Elysium versus
like a whole different feeling
this is delicious yeah it tastes like um
honey water really good honey water so
if you're not Korean and it's a hot day
there's a noise that you make
Muriel knows this noise cause she makes
it all the time that the situation we're
fighting great you go it's the mom it's
the most disgusting sound but Korean
people love making that noise it's a
symbol of it's refreshing and it just
hits the spot so I'm about to go on this
big-ass bridge and you guys know I'm
scared of heights but I'm gonna do it
anyways because we're all about life
experiences this old wooden Asian bridge
it looks like it was built yesterday by
a blind man who doesn't make bridges Oh
God who is shaking this bridge I'm gonna
are you walking backwards what is going
on hold on huh yes I can but why is it
shaking so much who built this bridge
stop don't stop okay keep going keep
going keep going keep going oh my god I
can't guy dude she has the guy I'm in
front of you how can i guide you that
does it make any sense
come on guys [ __ ] this I don't wanna do
this I don't want to do this oh my god
why is it moving we're almost there
Becca you do that tell me the bridge
moves you are a terrible person you stop
jumping
[Music]
before I'm not scared of anything
basically when you do things you got to
do it like a man there's no fear
whatsoever you tackle things like a
straight G you know I'm saying I took
that thing like it was I'm not even
scared of heights so I'm about to go
ahead and walk on this long-ass bridge
you guys know I'm scared of heights
[Music]
so we are here at the very first Din Tai
Fung ever out here in Taiwan now if
you're an LA native you already know
what the in Python is because Din Tai
Fung has some of the best soup dumplings
on earth and I'm not sure if that speaks
for the people here in Taiwan but it's
very popular back where I'm from I'm
super excited to try out the food now
the interesting thing about this Din Tai
Fung is the fact that the waitresses
here can actually speak Korean Japanese
English or Chinese and the cool thing
about that is they kind of cater to you
to make your service a lot more
comfortable so I'm really excited to see
what they have to offer here and the
food I believe is going to be amazing so
if you guys want to eat here and you
don't know how to eat the soup dumplings
interestingly enough they give you an
instructional card to do so so everybody
has only to eat food and I'm not really
dogmatic in the practices of how you eat
it I say eat it to the point where you
enjoy the mess about it but I guess
you're supposed to use one part soy
sauce three parts vinegar which is a
shit-ton in my personal pick but if
people tie one like it more vinegary
than I guess I have to eat it that way
to take the the dumpling and grab it
from the top so you don't tear it if it
into the sauce to get all the vinegar
and soy sauce put it in here pierce the
skin to let the soup out so you don't
burn the out of your face in your tongue
which I have done before when I coarse
ages that nobody told me and then you
take your amount of ginger that you like
that's already been marinating in the
soy sauce and vinegar then
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]